Our leaders are stupid.
Our politicians are stupid.
Donald Trump, who four short years ago was viewed by many GOP operatives as an erratic outsider,
has just been renominated as the party's standard bearer.
But whether he wins or loses, can a party without any guiding principles survive?
How do the political parties die? And how are new ones born?
Imagine a political party that has lost its ideological coherence and is torn apart by various warring factions,
then an outsider and celebrity candidate emerges
with no fealty to the party's policy agenda
and with no previous political experience.
He goes on to connect with voters
and retake the White House.
That's exactly what happened...
...in 1848
when the Whigs backed Zachary Taylor.
Political scientist Philip Wallach
is a resident senior fellow at the think tank the R Street Institute.
He published a 2017 paper on the parallels between Taylor and Trump